oh excuse me
have you ever yawn because somebody else
yawned you aren't especially tired yet
suddenly your mouth opens wide big comes
out this phenomenon is known as
contagious yawning and while scientists
still don't fully understand why it
happens
there are many hypotheses currently
being researched let's take a look at a
few of the most prevalent ones
beginning with to physiological
hypotheses before moving to a
psychological one
our first physiological hypotheses
states that contagious yawning is
triggered by a specific stimulus an
initial yawn this is called fixed action
pattern think of fixed action pattern
like reflex you're yawn makes me yawn
similar to a domino effect
one person's yawn triggers a yawn in a
person nearby that has observed the app
once this reflex is triggered it must
run its course have you ever tried to
stop me yawn once it has begun basically
impossible
another physiological hypothesis is
known as non conscious mimicry or the
chameleon effect this occurs when you
imitate someone's behavior without
knowing it a subtle and unintentional
copycat manoeuvre people tend to mimic
each other's postures if you are seated
across from someone that has their legs
crossed
you might cross your own legs this
hypothesis suggests that we yawn when we
see someone else yawn because we're
unconsciously copying his or her
behavior scientists believe that this
chameleon effect is possible because of
a special set of neurons known as mirror
neurons
mirror neurons are a type of brain cell
that responds equally when we perform an
action as when we see someone else
perform the same action these neurons
are important for learning and
self-awareness for example watching
someone do something physical like
knitting or putting on lipstick can help
you do those same actions more
accurately neuroimaging studies using
fMRI functional magnetic resonance
imaging shows that when we see someone
yawn or even hear their yawn a specific
area of the brain housing these mirror
neurons tends to light up which in turn
causes us to respond with the same
action a yawn our psychological
hypotheses also involves the work of
these mirror neurons we will call it the
empathy yawn empathy is the ability to
understand what someone else is feeling
and partake in their emotion a crucial
ability for social animals like us
recently neuroscientists have found that
a subset of mirror neurons allows us to
empathize with others feelings at a
deeper level scientists discovered this
empathetic response to yawning while
testing the first hypotheses we
mentioned fixed action pattern the study
was set up to show that dogs would enact
a yawn reflex at the mere sound of a
human yawn while their studies showed
this to be true they found something
else interesting dogs yawn more
frequently at familiar yawns such as
from their owners
then at unfamiliar yawns from strangers
following this research other studies on
humans and primates have also shown that
contagious yawning occurs more
frequently among friends than strangers
in fact contagious yawning starts
occurring when we are about four or five
years old at the point when children
develop the ability to identify other's
emotions properly still while newer
scientific studies aim to prove that
contagious yawning is based on this
capacity for empathy more research is
needed to shed light on what exactly is
going on it's possible that the answer
lies in another hypothesis altogether
the next time you get caught in a yawn
take a second to think about what just
happened
were you thinking about a yawn
did someone near you yawn was that
person a stranger or someone close
and are you yawning right now